alors on va vous faire vous savoir un
peu mieux qui vous êtes on va vous faire
une interview
si les coûts
est ce que vous êtes mégalo ans non plus
tout non vous n'êtes ni taux non plus
d'être parano nos plus schizo en
surpoids que tout le monde est un peu
s'attendent enfin bon c'est moi je suis
un peu de seins quand même
ouais le bruit beaucoup de défauts mais
le fait d'être si klaus est par
définition un peu schizo mais si qu un
peu oui les chicots vix qu'ils ont une
forme d'être maso non non pas du tout
vous n'aimez pas qu'on vous fasse mal
aux noms
ah bon mais pour chacun alors là il ya
des gens qui adorent ça oui oui par et
oui mais alors sa chance et j'ai
tellement con enfin bon est ce que vous
êtes ado sano non plus ils ont même
perdu leur élan pour toi moi j'ai de
piqué d'un poulet pas mais non je vous
êtes homo ou alors avec tout peut
arriver
tout peut arriver qu'un tout petit au
maroc
pourquoi oui de sa paume au body coller
aux français aussi vous avez d'avoir des
propositions aux français ce jeu vous
dire
donc je ne me suis jamais vu en papa
août et si vous voulez que je vous dise
c'est un peu verdun ce côté là mais il y
avait beaucoup
il y avait beaucoup de domofrance et de
gens qui avaient beaucoup de talent et
on allait vraiment danser dans le jeu
vous savez ils ont tendance à vous
féminisé et on m'avait féminisé lors
d'une tournée parce que j'étais quand
vous aurez là galabru non en main on
m'appelait parce que j'étais robert
hirsch il avait beaucoup de l'esprit et
m'appeler rosa pichon et rosa pulsions
et bien vous savez on se sent un peu
femme à ce moment là donc c'est pas
aller plus loin
non non non nous on est restés à rosas
mon nom est ce que vous êtes gros lolos
gros lolos à wimby
le réservoir le site petit lolo à 1
je suis lui au complet voilà que senghor
salle tous extraordinaires et je
regrette de ne pas l'avoir
voilà quoi que oui est ce que vous êtes
trio trio à attention à vous mes enfants
je vais pas être faux derche et dans mon
temps à l'époque trio j'ai goûté ouais
c'est pas mauvais la fecq deux femmes
alors mes canons parce que vous êtes
exhibo non pas du tout hagi mohamud
acteurs est toujours existant interview
au premier chef de labro le gall voilà
si on était un film hongrois poids non
c'est vrai s'il y en a mais vous l'avez
loupé j'étais figurant dans la bataille
du social business sur les pompiers et
ont passé les culés les comme on appelle
ça le conseil de révision
donc comme j'étais figurants nous habite
tous nus et moi j'ai eu le malheur de me
trouvais juste à la porte du médecin
donc pour raccorder au mal et c'est là
toute une journée tout nu avec la script
qui dotés tous les détails travelo de
[ __ ] n'ont jamais essayé
gt gt d'acajou fois que j'étais enfin
votre ado est commun
une femme est acteur l'alu automne y a10
devait me rouler une pelle et la refuser
pourquoi il à dire me voyant et aurore
launay très bien est ce que vous êtes
rocco rocco et ses frères recours que
ces frais d un look aussi fred et rocco
siffredi ouais qu'est-ce que je
connaissais pas rocco siffredi non vous
connaissez pas possible année les nuits
ce clip et de m'excuser mais je connais
à la campagne qu'est ce que c'est rocco
siffredi sait pas se taper une faune et
à aller frayer un peu tout ça est monté
comme un âne allons à non non non non
j'ai pas de détails venir mais c'est pas
rocco ses parts au coccyx poco a je
pense qu'on sera là est ce que vous êtes
adamo ah j'adore à dabo est ce que vous
êtes disco oblong chez plus de mon âge
je crois va essayer
at on dit mais j'ai plein marion